tu as quitté le métier ouais
complètement
comme on pouvait on sortait la tête de
l'eau et puis bah facture d'énergie on
fait que ils ont deux mois quoi
et donc impossible tu pouvais pas t'en
sortir non non impossible on travaille
pour rien terminé pour toi complètement
on est clairement en train de tuer le
métier c'est fini les boulangeries on en
aura parce que là avec ce qui vient de
tomber on va en parler dans un instant
avec Damien et avec ce qui vient de
tomber là il y a plus de bouclier au
niveau de la facture d'électricité pour
les boulangers tu peux nous rappeler le
oui donc le bouclier tarifaire va être
suspendu à la fin de l'année pour les
boulangers c'est à dire que le ministre
Lescure dit le tarif de l'électricité du
gaz Bessan il y a plus besoin alors il
prend la précaution il dit pour
l'instant avec une sorte de clause de
revoyure mais ça a été le choc parce que
c'est prorogé pour les particuliers et
les boulangers et tous les petits
commerces se retrouvent d'un coup sans
doute obligé de payer des fortunes donc
c'est le choc monumental dans l'opinion
alors donc aujourd'hui Julien
pour toi tu dis c'est c'est complètement
fini moi je suis dans l'usine automobile
maintenant et tu as changé toi
complètement
usine automobile d'accord et là tu étais
bien ouais je suis mes heures j'ai mon
salaire qui rentre j'ai plus le stress
et la pression derrière tu gagnes après
avoir été boulanger
je sais pas j'arrive à me sortir 1008 à
peu près au départ après tu arrives à
sortir ouais bien sûr quand ça a
commencé avec les factures d'électricité
rien du tout et en plus c'est mon DT à
la fin c'est ouais donc tu gagnes mieux
ta vie aujourd'hui
tu t'es à moins de pression c'est ça il
y a moins de pression derrière mais il y
a plus de stress ouais et plus heureux
maintenant
plus non je pense pas mais c'est une vie
différente parce que c'était ta passion
complètement pour toi il y aura plus de
boulanger dans quelques temps c'est
ouais on est on y vient là moi je vois
dans ma région donc en Lorraine je vois
que dans tout le secteur chez nous même
des grosses boulangeries on croit qu'ils
ont les insolites mais en fait non l'un
derrière les autres il ferme pour toi
c'est une onde ça de ce qui vient
j'ai bien fait de me barrer tu pouvais
plus tenir ah bah non je pouvais plus
tenir toute façon clairement c'était
terminé pour toi alors on est avec
Damien aussi qui est il a 32 ans il est
boulanger dans le 91 vous êtes boulanger
depuis combien de temps Damien moi ça
fait 16 ans que je suis boulanger 16 ans
16 ans que je suis boulanger ouais vous
avez démarré à 16 ans j'ai démarré à 15
ans ouais non fort ouais
non pas du tout non non j'ai des parents
hors milieu carrément je suis tombé dans
quand j'étais petit en stage et du coup
stage en boulangerie et puis du coup
vous avez ouvert votre boulangerie il y
a quatre ans et demi il y a 4 ans et
demi avant vous travaillez dans d'autres
boulangeries exactement sur Paris tout
le temps et là vous êtes dit ça y est
c'est bon c'est mon moment l'objectif de
tout boulanger passionné c'est d'ouvrir
son commerce et d'arriver à
l'aboutissement final d'avoir un nom sur
une devanture et voilà mais clairement
aujourd'hui on commence à être dégoûté
et alors justement on va en parler
ça a bien démarré vous travaillez bien
au départ il y a 4 ans ça a bien démarré
quoi ça a bien démarré ouais c'était
content très bien démarré de toute façon
on a ouais je suis content on a fait un
chiffre en constante augmentation depuis
4 ans et là et là alors là on va en
parler parce que
aujourd'hui si on compare il y a deux
ans vous payez beaucoup plus
d'électricité c'est quoi la différence
on payait beaucoup plus de tristes non
en fait là j'ai réduit ma consommation
mais je paye plus d'accord un contrario
c'est à dire donc ça veut dire que
grossièrement parlant je consomme un
tiers d'électricité en moins mais je
paye le double aujourd'hui si j'aurais
pas réduit intelligemment on va dire les
choses au max arrêtez les cuissons
l'après-midi pour faire moins chaud au
client
j'en serais pas avoir je pourrais pas
aujourd'hui espérer sortir la tête de
l'eau mais beaucoup de mes confrères ils
ont la tête dans l'eau et ferme le jour
en jour là encore ce mois-ci j'en ai
deux qui c'est quoi le moins c'est
combien vous payer d'électricité par
mois moi je paye 2000 euros
d'électricité par mois c'est beaucoup
j'ai terminé l'avant d'accord donc vous
avez doublé mais bon j'ai doublé avec
les aides comprise parce que les aides
c'est de la poudre c'est-à-dire c'est de
la poudre c'est que dalle 300 euros
d'aide c'est ridicule c'est pas par quoi
par mois par mois c'est rien du tout
quand on fait un X 2 j'aurais dû faire
2004 et je fais 2100 à la place de 1000
euros à la base d'accord donc en fait
votre facture d'électricité électricité
elle était à 2004 il y a l'aide donc il
y a 2100 mais vous étiez à 1000 euros à
la base donc voilà c'était c'était à
plus de 50% de de d'augmentation x 2 et
x 2 encore moi je suis en privilégié
d'autres c'est pas ça cette fois-ci là
j'ai un boulanger de Strasbourg en
sachant en fait que je venais là et j'ai
eu des centaines de messages parce que
nous on qu'est-ce qu'ils vous ont dit
les boulangers
il faut dénoncer la vérité il faut dire
la vérité il lui comment ça facture
d'électricité lui il a pris un X6 il est
passé de 1000 à 6000 non ah ouais et la
500 euros d'aide c'est ridicule alors
l'amortisseur c'est pareil j'ai d'autres
collègues à moi il passe ça fait depuis
janvier ils ont pas reçu leur facture on
est au mois de mai c'est très grave et
ceux qui ont reçu des fois sans
amortisseur ou avec des amortisseurs
erronées ou alors dans ce cas-là on est
sur d'autres fournisseurs qui appliquent
leur propre loi ou leur propre règle
c'est complètement débile en fait désolé
de dire ça mais c'est complètement
débile vous savez augmenter les prix de
vos produits ouais ça fait deux fois
déjà
passé vous avez fait deux fois 20%. non
deux fois 10% d'accordier mais même ça
ça suffit pas j'ai dû licencier deux
personnes je fais 80 heures semaine je
suis pas payé moi je me paye pas ah ça y
est il avance on fait depuis 5 mois que
je le paye pas rien j'ai deux gosses à
gérer j'ai je passe des journées
entières au boulot j'en profite pas j'ai
pas de vie et derrière j'ai des crédits
sur le dos encore plus lourd des charges
encore plus lourdes il faut arrêter on
est on est on est des tonnes comme ça
des milliers et au bout d'un moment faut
qu'il prenne conscience et là l'arrêt du
bouclier tarifaire mais on va où quoi
stop on là pour vous quand vous avez
appris ça vous êtes dit quoi c'est la
fin pour moi
je vais pas vous mentir je suis enfin je
suis quelqu'un de très optimiste à la
base mais là plus les mois passent plus
on est on est pessimiste qu'on arrête
quoi il y en a beaucoup qui s'arrêtent
ils Flandre les parents à Jérémy
justement qui est venu plusieurs fois
ici ça y est là ils arrêtent à la fin du
mois ils en peuvent plus son père et la
61 ans il va se retrouver avec la
réforme des retraites en plus à devoir
rebosser à son âge après des des années
des années de patronat comme ça c'est
abusé c'est aberrant il va repartir tout
avec des dettes c'est pareil ils ont
fait quatre fois et demi leur somme avec
un amortisseur dégueulasse quoi désolé
quand ça marche bien vous arrivez à vous
payer
je touchais 1200 euros c'est pas mal
déjà pour 80 heures non c'est et là
aujourd'hui c'est zéro c'est zéro que
dalle 0 vous avez augmenté donc de 10 %
plus de 10 %, encore qu'est-ce que vous
avez dit à vos clients pour cette
augmentation est-ce qu'il vous ont dit
quelque chose en fait la chose que j'ai
c'est que je fais du fait maison et de
la qualité donc ma réputation en fait on
va dire elle est déjà fait des dégâts
comme vous avec ce qui se passe là dans
6 mois il y en aura plus mais il y en a
déjà qui font des crédits pour payer
leurs factures attention il y en a ils
bosse deux fois plus ils sont si les
salariés donc au bout d'un moment
physiquement et moralement il y aura des
morts c'est
peut-être dur oui ce que je veux dire
mais il y aura des morts très clairement
et là on peut plus on peut plus se faire
berner comme ça c'est fini vous dites
quoi vos clients me soutiennent et sont
tous derrière nous enfin vous leur avez
vous leur avez annoncé vous leur avez
dit je suis obligé d'augmenter vous leur
avez dit quoi bah eux ils me soutiennent
j'aurais dit je suis obligé d'augmenter
parce que les matières premières ont
augmenté déjà 1 les factures d'énergie
de augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat a
baisser farine on peut entre 30 et 40%
c'est énorme j'ai mon meunier il se fait
exploser bien sûr je suis désolé après
je peux pas lui taper dessus lui dire
non tu augmenter farine tu déconnes
qu'est-ce qui a augmenté encore le
beurre il a pris plus de 60% le sucre on
parle au kilo et là il est passé de 80
centimes à 1,20 la levure elle a pris
50%
faut pas déconner les emballages
en fait aujourd'hui le prix de ta
baguette il coûte beaucoup plus cher ta
valeur moi je fais une baguette bio déjà
à la base c'est de la farine bio donc
faut savoir que c'est plus cher du top
qualité grossièrement parlant j'ai
augmenté de 20 centimes je suis passé un
euro 40 ma baguette 1 € 40 pour les gens
des fois c'est trop cher ou il y en a
qui j'ai augmenté de 10 centimes le
dernier palier il y en a ils m'ont dit
ça y est c'est trop cher pour plus de
pain ouais mais faut arrêter là pour
s'en sortir faudrait passer la baguette
à trois balles non mais je crois pas que
personne peut payer une baguette à 3
balles aujourd'hui bien sûr ben non
honnêtement donc au bout d'un moment il
va falloir arrêter les des bêtises
surtout que les industriels se gavent de
dire ça il se gave ils mettent leur prix
moi j'ai comparé ma baguette céréales
que je fais bio aussi 1,60 je la vends
d'accord l'industriel le vend à 1,80 je
citerai pas le nom de la chaîne mais
j'ai vu ça je suis tombé de haut j'ai
dit attends mais j'ai fait mais
c'est pas possible quoi on va où quoi on
va où l'artisanat ils le vende l'UNESCO
tout ça c'est super mais honnêtement ça
va pas nous sauver tout ça il va falloir
qu'il se réveille il faut sortir du
marché européen comment tu t'en sors
aujourd'hui parce que tu es tu me dis tu
gagnes pas
faut arrêter j'ai des enfants derrière
j'ai ça à gérer moi tant qu'ils ont
mangé dans leur assiette ça me va tu te
réveilles à quelle heure le matin moi je
me réveille à 4h du mat je te couches à
quelle heure tu finis à quelle heure le
travail ça dépend voilà vu que j'ai
moins de personnel je fais la vente
l'après-midi donc en gros je boucle la
boutique à 19h30 en train de faire mon
ménage tout 21h je fais 4h du matin 21h
voilà exactement et tu me dis
aujourd'hui tu as zéro ou en poche j'ai
zéro balle 0 balle ce qui me reste en
fait grossièrement parlant c'est c'est
l'aide de mes parents j'ai de la chance
d'avoir des parents qui sont non mais
non mais est-ce que tu te rends compte
de ce que tu dis parce que c'est ça
c'est ce que je dis tous les jours c'est
à dire que eux tes parents en plus ils
doivent se dire tu avais mon fils le
pauvre il travaille de 4h du matin
jusqu'à 21h et et et on est obligé de
l'aider parce que aujourd'hui il s'en
sort pas
et puis après derrière moi je demande
pas après on demande pas le mode non
mais est-ce que tu viens de me dire il y
a un instant tu m'as dit à 1200 euros tu
étais tu étais content je m'en sortais
ouais parce que voilà mais
les places ou ou avant je touchais 3000
€ par mois et tout voilà là je suis
patron je me suis dit attends j'ai
cravacher pour arriver là j'arrive ici
même 1200 euros bon j'arrivais à
bricoler et tout ça va mais derrière au
bout d'un moment on peut plus et puis là
sans argent on peut pas bien sûr on peut
pas comment tu fais on peut pas
comme je dis mes parents c'est simple
ils sont là derrière économie de bout de
chandelle voilà et puis après je mange
voilà il me reste des invendus et tout
je mange des invendus
je me plains pas on va dire qu'on a pire
que soit dans la vie d'accord j'ai la
santé ça va j'ai mes enfants ils sont en
bonne santé et aussi ça me va mais après
au bout d'un moment on travaille pas
bénévolement ça veut dire que nous
derrière on a fait le choix d'être
patron justement pour prospérer et
justement vivre de notre passion mais
n'en peux plus Damien aujourd'hui là on
est on est aujourd'hui le 24 avril
tu me dis ça fait cinq mois que tu te
payes pas là le gouvernement l'a annoncé
il y a pas de bouclier au niveau de
l'électricité pour les entreprises donc
pas pour toi donc pas pour les
boulangers tu te tu te donnes combien de
temps que tu te dis que tu peux tenir
combien de temps parce que tu me dis là
déjà tu as plus rien mais moi j'ai le en
fait on va dire tout simplement j'ai le
la passion qui me tient encore la
passion qui me tient encore l'envie
aussi de m'en sortir parce que je me dis
le combat on le mène depuis septembre
nous on dénonce depuis septembre on
dénonce on a envoyé des messages à tout
le monde ici je prends sur le plateau ça
sera Raymond tout on a envoyé des
messages à tout le monde j'ai Maxime qui
est venu Jérémy on envoie tous les
boulangers mais Isabelle qui était venu
là c'est nous elle vient de chez nous
l'association U Dhabi qu'on a créé et
justement on se bat depuis des mois donc
moi dans mon optique je veux pas fermer
je veux pas crever je veux pas m'arrêter
ça veut dire que je me bats jusqu'au
bout jusqu'au dernier souffle au bout
d'un moment voilà la santé physique et
tout d'abord si je peux plus si mon
corps est là je veux dire STOP moi j'ai
un gars dans ma vie de qui a fermé là au
début du mois là et tout mais toi
aujourd'hui demain tu peux tenir combien
de temps pour gagner sans rien gagner
je peux pas tenir bref je peux pas te
tenir je peux tenir peut-être deux trois
mois jusqu'à l'été là après stop je vais
tirer je vais tirer l'alarme stop
pourquoi si tu vas faire tu vas fermer
toi aussi
on travaille pas on travaille pas dans
des conditions comme ça sous perfusion
c'est pas bon pour notre santé nous
c'est pas bon mais ça aujourd'hui est-ce
que le gouvernement le sait parce qu'on
en a parlé ici il voit pas qu'il y a des
boulangeries qui ferment toutes les
semaines que toutes les semaines là
aujourd'hui les spectateurs qui nous
rejoignent il est 21h06 on est en direct
dans TPMP
des boulangeries à tripola dans deux ans
il y en a une interpellé tout le monde
interpellé Olivia Grégoire qui nous a
dit qu'on avait sorti des calculs
tapothicaires attendez rendez-vous
compte ça m'a dit que ça match en plus
c'est ça le pire donc au bout d'un
moment quand nous disent oui voilà il le
voyait pas ça alors ils vendent des
chiffres comme quoi il y a plus de
boulangerie qui ouvre qui ferme d'accord
sauf que il ouvre le détail alors des
points chauds on appelle des
boulangeries des points chauds ou des
industriels ça compte dans des
boulangeries non je pense pas donc les
vrais artisans ils crèvent aujourd'hui
bien sûr et ça continue à les
industriels se frottent les mains désolé
de dire ça donc au bout d'un moment il
va falloir qu'ils soient notre
patrimoine sinon on est en train de le
faire crever à l'étranger la boulangerie
française est reconnue c'est vrai
incroyablement moi j'ai envie de me
barrer très clairement j'ai des amis à
moi qui sont partis à l'étranger mais
ils écartonne moi j'ai mes enfants en
France
il y a des baguettes qui se vendent et
qui volent 4 roues ici je sais ils se
les arrache nous ici on peut moi j'ai eu
le bras droit de lever Grégoire en ligne
plusieurs fois
je l'ai eu en ligne et je lui ai dit
mais vous ils accepteraient enfin je
sais pas
j'accepterait de travailler 80 heures
semaine et pas vous payer et tout il me
dit bah non voilà vous accepterez pas ça
vous trouvez ça normal que la
boulangerie française on puisse pas où
vivre en France c'est ça c'est grave
surtout moi je suis passionné je veux
pas arrêter de manger j'ai pas envie
d'arrêter aller partir dans l'automobile
ou faire des trucs ou des plateaux j'en
ai rien à voir voilà moi mon métier
c'est la boulangerie c'est ma passion
j'ai envie de transmettre tu le
transmets à des jeunes tous les jours
j'ai plein d'apprentis aujourd'hui et
vous voyez beaucoup de boulanger se
marie j'en vois plein j'en vois plein là
il y a Sully Strasbourg et il a racheté
une boutique 450 000 €, il a fait 150
000 € de travaux dedans d'accord
aujourd'hui là il a mangé un X 6 en
électricité par rapport à novembre
d'accord il me dit Damien je vais crever
c'est mort elle est mort terminée je
viens d'arriver je suis déjà mort et les
anciens c'est pareil mon pote Jérémy
c'est parents un mot c'est exactement
pareil faut dire qu'ils sont arrivés et
attendez ils sont en fin de carrière ça
respectables ils ont 30 ans de métier 30
ans de boîte d'accord et vous repartir
une mort devant derrière 30 ans limite
avec des dettes c'est grave
c'est grave c'est très très grave c'est
et au bout d'un moment c'est on va dire
que c'est non assistance à boulanger
enfin personne en danger que ce soit
toutes les TPE je parle pas que des
boulangers forcément attention c'est
meurtrier parce que c'est c'est il y a
beaucoup de TP de PME qui vont fermer là
les défaillances cette année par rapport
à 2022 il y a 44 % d'augmentation c'est
des chiffres officiels attention 44 %
d'augmentation on est entre 55000 et
60000 défaillances ça veut dire
liquidation redressement judiciaire
c'est pas possible il faut arrêter oh au
bout d'un moment faut regarder les gens
dans les yeux surtout désolé le
gouvernement là du coup va falloir se
bouger un peu si Macron il regarde ça
mais quand il vous dit on a on a reçu
les Grégoire ici elle a dit qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'aide pour les
boulangers
[Musique]
allez hop 40000 donc 140000 euros pour
un artisan possible
au bout d'un moment comment tu fais est
mort donc après nous on nous dit ça moi
j'ai fait un étalon de paiement je me
suis dit ok total énergie accepté on dit
ok on vous étale le premier paiement là
ok pour l'instant je peux étaler
d'accord deuxième fois que tu vas
arriver ou dans deux mois au bout d'un
moment je vais leur dire attends je vais
rajouter sur le retallage donc du coup
ça ou je vais faire un crédit peut-être
après le PSG le covid parce que le covid
on est le dollar aussi bien sûr le covid
nous on est resté ouvert les boulangers
c'est des vaillant ok super mais on n'a
pas été attention on a perdu beaucoup
d'argent pendant le covid Julien toi tu
étais c'est fini pour toi tu es dans
l'automobile
là justement moi j'ai reçu un courrier
encore la semaine dernière que j'étais
pas éligible à une aide après laquelle
je serai pas à te dire laquelle en
particulier mais je sais que ma
comptable a été démené elle avait fait
plein de dossiers et tout machin et là
la semaine dernière j'ai encore reçu tu
bois 3 ou 4 mois après après la guerre
quoi aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'était ta
passion la boulangerie complètement
tu es triste de plus exercer ton métier
ta passion d'un côté oui d'un côté non
parce que tu vois maintenant
quand je vois tous les sacrifices que
j'ai fait pendant tant d'années avoir ça
au final tu vois je me dis que
moi
janvier moi je te dis j'ai fait une
dépression mais j'étais sur le canapé
bouffer des cachets et tout machin je
voyais personne tu vois mieux là et là
je remercie un de mes anciens clients si
nous regardent m'avoir fait rentrer dans
l'usine automobile quoi et franchement
ouais c'est ma redonner du bon moqueur
tu vois et ça j'en ai plein tous les
jours moi qui m'envoie des messages j'en
ai plein les messages en me disant
Damien je vais me pendre mais non mais
c'est c'est céréales
femme de Toulouse qui est toute seule à
gérer une boulangerie d'accord elle est
tout seul à gérer une boulangerie elle
m'a dit au bout d'un moment Damien elle
me dit je sais plus je sais plus à qui
parler
par exemple je suis voilà je suis solo
j'ai mes enfants quand j'ai pas mes
enfants je suis solo à la maison on
finit le boulot des fois avec des
journées bien chargées on est malade
tout on n'a pas le droit de s'arrêter
attention moi je me suis je me suis je
me suis défoncé la cheville je me suis
pas dit non non je vais m'arrêter oh non
ben non tu as pas le droit de t'arrêter
tu peux pas tu t'arrêtes tu fermes une
journée tu perds 1000 balles fini tu
fais quoi tu peux pas rideau stop on
peut pas on est prêt à la gorge c'est
lui ton travail 7 sur 7
80 heures semaine c'est énorme
si on n'a pas une bonne hygiène de vie
on est mort on est cuit donc au bout
d'un moment il va falloir que ça y est
ils prennent ils prennent leur
responsabilités ils assument un petit
peu voilà simplement tu vas te réveiller
demain matin bien sûr j'aimerais vivre
tous les matins je me réveille tu gardes
la tu gardes espoir mais j'ai toujours
espoir sinon je serais pas là vous
parlez pour vraiment un peu le
incroyable que ça ne bouge pas du tout
je te jure ça nous rend fou depuis
septembre parce que ça fait des semaines
et des semaines un boulanger par jour on
avait parlé seul justement